welcome to the second chapter of the  kind to the defense against the human  invasion today's lesson the right  choices make a tremendous difference on  the battlefield find your streets and  use them to your advantage chapter two  the Arsenal at your disposal it with  precision and keep Earthlings at a  distance with blaster and enforcer  cannons  let's go big deal vast area damage using  behemoths  or shake the world to its foundations  with a mighty scorcher  deceive the invaders change their roots  with harvesters and lure them into traps  reach further  take no prisoners  I almost pity those humans they'll be  like sitting ducks almost victory is at  hand failure will be punished for the  hive commander  Oh